>> Tucker: WE LIVE IN THE AGE
OF WOKE CAPITAL.
THAT MEANS IS NO LONGER ENOUGH
FOR A COMPANY TO SELL YOU A
PRODUCT YOU WANT TO BUY.
THEY SELL YOU A WORLDVIEW
WHETHER YOU WANT IT OR NOT.
GOOGLE LECTURES ABOUT DIVERSITY.
STARBUCKS TELLS YOU YOU ARE A
RACIST, AND THE NBA IS NO
EXCEPTION TO THIS VIEW.
THEY PULLED THE ALL-STAR GAME
OUT OF NORTH CAROLINA BECAUSE OF
THE STATE'S POLICY ON
TRANSGENDER BATHROOMS.
NBA PLAYERS READILY MAKE
LEFT-WING POLITICAL STATEMENTS
AND THE LEAGUE APPROVES OF THAT.
BUT IT TURNS OUT THAT THERE'S A
LIMIT OF FREEDOM OF SPEECH OVER
THERE IN BASKETBALL WORLD.
OVER THE WEEKEND, HOUSTON
ROCKETS GENERAL MANAGER DARYL
MOREY TWEETED SUPPORT FOR THE
PRO-DEMOCRACY PROTESTERS IN
HONG KONG.
THAT IMPLIED CRITICISM OF
CHINA'S FASCIST GOVERNMENT.
AND THAT WAS TOO MUCH FOR THE
NBA.
THE TWEET WAS DELETED AND THE
NBA IMMEDIATELY GROVELED TO
CHINA'S AUTHORITARIAN AMERICA
HATING LEADERS.
THE LEAGUE ISSUED AN APOLOGY,
MAKING IT CLEAR THAT MAURY DID
NOT REPRESENT THE NBA.
HE MAY SUPPORT FREEDOM AND
DEMOCRACY, BUT THE NBA DOES NOT.
J.D. VANCE IS THE AUTHOR OF
HILLBILLY ELEGY AND ONE OF THE
CLEAREST THINKERS OF MODERN
POLITICS.
WHAT DOES THIS TELL US ABOUT THE
NBA AND WOKE CAPITAL, MORE
GENERALLY?
>> TUCKER, SOME OF THE EXAMPLES
YOU HIGHLIGHTED, STARBUCKS
PICKING A SIDE WITHIN AMERICAN
POLITICS, TARGET PICKING SIDES
WITH AMERICAN POLITICS DURING
THESE COMPANIES' POSITIONS MIGHT
BE STUPID, BUT THEY CAN AT LEAST
SAY THEY ARE CHOOSING THE SITE
OF AN AMERICAN POLITICAL
INTEREST.
IN THE CASE OF CHINA, WHETHER
IT'S APPLE HELPING THE CHINESE
SECURITY STATE, WHETHER IT'S
HOLLYWOOD BOWING DOWN BEFORE
CHINA, OR IN THIS CASE THE NBA
BOWING DOWN BEFORE CHINA, THESE
COMPANIES CANNOT EVEN CLAIM THEY
ARE DEFENDING AN AMERICAN VALUE
OR AN AMERICAN INTEREST.
I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS IT
TELLS US IS THAT AMERICAN
BUSINESS INTERESTS, IF THEY SEE
THE ALMIGHTY DOLLAR IN THE HANDS
OF A FOREIGN RIVAL, THEY'LL GO
AND CHASE IT EVEN IF IT'S NOT IN
THE BEST INTEREST OF THEIR OWN
COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: NOT IN THE BEST
INTEREST?
I MEAN, THIS IS OUR PREEMINENT
RIVAL, ENEMY ACTUALLY I THINK
FROM THEIR PERSPECTIVE ON THE
WORLD STAGE.
A COUNTRY THAT'S ABOUT TO
OVERTAKE US ECONOMICALLY AND
MILITARILY.
SIDING WITH THEM SEEMS LIKE A
PROFOUND BETRAYAL.
>> IT'S A PROFOUND BETRAYAL IN A
COUPLE OF DIFFERENT WAYS,
TUCKER.
THE FIRST IS WHAT YOU MENTIONED.
I THINK WE ARE IN THE
GEOPOLITICAL STRUGGLE WITH CHINA
UNLIKE ANYTHING WE'VE SEEN SINCE
AT LEAST THE EARLY 1930s WITH
GERMANY.
WE ARE NOT YET AT PHYSICAL WAR
AND HOPEFULLY OF COURSE WE DON'T
GO TO WAR WITH CHINA.
BUT WE ARE IN A STRUGGLE REALLY
FOR GLOBAL PREEMINENCE WITH THIS
COUNTRY AND THEY HAVE AMBITIONS
TO BE A GLOBAL SUPERPOWER.
THAT IS NECESSARILY GOING TO
TAKE THEM IN COMPETITION WITH
US.
THE OTHER WAY THIS IS A REALLY
SIGNIFICANT BETRAYAL OF AMERICAN
VALUES IS THAT CHINA ACTIVELY
DOES SO MANY OF THE THINGS THAT
THE LEFT SAYS THAT IT HATES
ABOUT OUR OWN COUNTRY.
YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT ISLAMIC
PERSECUTION?
THE CHINESE ARE RUNNING ACTUAL
CONCENTRATION CAMPS FOR SOME OF
ITS ISLAMIC POPULATION IN CHINA.
YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT TREATING
GENDER MINORITIES FAIRLY, WHICH
IS THE FAVORITE TOPIC OF THE
LEFT OF THESE DAYS, GO TRY TO
FIND A TRANSGENDER BATHROOM IN
CHINA.
FIND A TWO GENDER BATHROOM IN
THE STATE OF CHINA.
THEY ARE ACTIVELY DOING THINGS
THAT PEOPLE IN THESE
COUNTRIES ACTIVELY HATE.
REPUBLICANS DO IT IT'S THE
TARGET OF CRITICISM.
BUT WHEN THE CHINESE DO IT,
PEOPLE SEEM TO BE OKAY WITH A
VIOLATION OF CORE VALUES.
OF COURSE, TUCKER, AS YOU
PROBABLY KNOW, THE MOST
EGREGIOUS HYPOCRISY ON THIS
FRONT IS CLIMATE CHANGE.
IF YOU ACTUALLY BUY THE ARGUMENT
ACHIEVING CO2 LEVELS, THE WORST
OFFENDER BY FAR IS CHINA.
THERE ARE A REASON THAT THEY GO
AFTER AMERICAN CONSUMERS BUT
DON'T GO AFTER CHINA AND THAT
MAKES IT PRETTY CLEAR IT HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH CLIMATE
CHANGE, IT HAS TO DO WITH
FRANKLY TAKING THE SIDE OF THE
REALLY VILE REGIME OVER THE
COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: THE CHINESE DON'T
HATE THEMSELVES, DO THEY?
>> NO THEY DON'T, TUCKER AND
THAT'S ONE OF THE CRAZIEST
THINGS ABOUT CHINA.
IF IT'S CHINESE NATIONALS LIVING
OVERSEAS OR IN WESTERN EUROPE,
WHETHER IT'S FOLKS WHO GO ON A
STUDENT VISA AND COME BACK, IT'S
PRETTY CLEAR THAT CHINA IS VERY
GOOD AT ENSURING ITS OWN
CITIZENS ACTUALLY LOVE THE
COUNTRY.
I DON'T THINK THERE IS A WHOLE
LOT LOVABLE ABOUT THE CHINESE
NATION THESE DAYS, BUT THEY ARE
VERY GOOD AT MAKING THEIR OWN
CITIZENS PATRIOTIC.
UNFORTUNATELY, WE HAVE A COUNTRY
THAT HAS A LOT -- WE HAVE A LOT
TO BE PROUD OF IN AMERICA BUT
UNFORTUNATELY A LOT OF FOLKS
DON'T THINK THAT THIS COUNTRY IS
SOMETHING TO BE PROUD OF.
WHEN YOU'RE IN A GLOBAL
GEOPOLITICAL STRUGGLE WHERE ONE
NATION IS AFRAID OF IT'S OWN
SHADOW AND THE OTHER NATION IS
PROUD OF ITSELF, IT'S NOT TOO
DIFFICULT TO IMAGINE WHICH
NATION IS GOING TO WIN.
I THINK BECAUSE OF THIS, TUCKER,
WHEN REALLY IMPORTANT POINT IN
ALL OF THIS, WE HAVE TO BE
WILLING TO PUSH BACK AGAINST
THIS STUFF USING POLITICAL
POWER.
YOU KNOW I'M A REPUBLICAN, BUT
ONE OF THE THINGS I DON'T LIKE
ABOUT THE REPUBLICAN PARTY THESE
DAYS IS THAT WE ARE AFRAID OF
ACTUALLY USING POLITICAL POWER.
THERE ARE THINGS WE CAN DO TO
PUSH BACK AGAINST THESE
COMPANIES THAT ARE TAKING THE
SIDE OF CHINA OVER AMERICA.
AND WITH THE NBA, WE CAN GO
AFTER THEIR STADIUM SUBSIDIES.
WHAT HAPPENED LAST TIME WE HAD
SIGNIFICANT POLITICAL POWER?
THE VERY SAME COMPANIES TAKING
THE SIDE OF CHINA OVER AMERICANS
AND AMERICAN CONSUMERS GOT A BIG
TAX BREAK.
WE CAN'T KEEP DOING THIS.
WE CAN'T KEEP SHOOTING OURSELVES
IN THE FOOT.